(Screaming loudly)
(Loud Freddy jumpscare)
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to "The Joy of Creation: REBORN".
Now, this is the game that I was telling you about in the last one, made by the same person,
but this one involves free-roaming, which means that I'll be exploring the house that they're all in.
And... if lovely Freddy out there is any indication, this is going to be a joyous time.
Yes, you! Talking about you, buddy! Let's have fun together!
Let's discover the  **Joy of Creation**...
Now, if you remember "The Joy of Creation" is actually an excerpt from something
that was in the first Five Nights at Freddy's game.
(whispering)
And in the first Five Night at Freddy's game we-
(silence)
Oh . . .
OOOOOOOOOOOOH!
I haven't played this before, I haven't even seen gameplay!
HELLO!
WHO'RE YOU?
Am I uh- huh, Am I an- huhu...
Am I an animatronic?
Oh, man. Hello!
Ah!
(Hellish jazz plays)
My jam!
Okay...
Well, it sure is setting the mood for something horrible to happen.
Whoa, what the fu-
uoaaAAA I broke it!
OH GOD I BROKE IT!
Whoops!
Okay!
I fell through the floor there. It's just an Alpha, by the by!
In case you guys didn't know.
Okay! We're back. I'm not gonna do that again.
Not gonna try to break the game.
So apparently, I'm an animatronic.
And, this is what I'm talking about-
"Hey..."
How's it going there?
Oh...
Okay,  It's really dark.
Also, where's my arm? I may not actually be an animatronic...
But if I am, I'm...
I'm a little curious as to why I'm roaming around the house.
Oh am I stalking someone?
(Freddy loudly sneaking up)
*Loud Freddy stomps*
AHHHHHHHHHHHHH  (Freddy jumpscare)
FUCK!
(Please wait while Markiplier.exe restarts...)
Oh...
WHAT HAPPENED!?
Oh my god!
I just hear this thumping behind m- ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I didn't even know if that was like, in the game or in real life!
I was like taking a legitimate moment to be like;
"Huh! Is someone banging on my door?"
Holy shit!
What the fuck was that!?
Okay, so apparently I'm not stalking anybody, I'm still being stalked.
*door slams into wall*
Oh fuck...
Okay, so apparently there's a trap down there...
(mark is focused)
That's a phone...
AHHH, come on, man?!
So I'm gonna avoid any walls altogether, because apparently the floor is VERY fragile.
*Freddy footsteps*
Oh shit.
Oh shit, dude.
(Distant thumping of angry gym equipment)
Oh shit dude.
(Banging gets louder)
(silent)
(Markiplier's face silently stretches in pure horror)
(silence)
(quietness lol)
(Re-adjusts pants due to new developments)
(still silent with banging)
AaAa
(The suspense!)
(laugh)
Hey buddy!
I'm glad my microphone isn't in the- really in the game!
Holy shit, what the fuck dude?!
What the fuck, man?!
I don't even know what my objective is.
Other than just to survive!
Okay. I really don't know what I'm trying to go for here.
I really don't know!
[Distant thunder]
Is there anything that I need to get?
Because I can't see a- [click]
ooo, I have a flashlight! (XD)
I didn't know-
Is he going away?
Better be going away from me.
(silence)
(Whispering) Hi buddy! Hey, how's it going?
I really don't want to run into him again, but I don't know why I'm here!
Ohhhh my god!
He coming this way?
*thumping gets closer* (scared monkey noises)
What is that?
Baseball cap? I'll take that!
Oh my god, oh my god!
OHH, that wasn't a stumpy robot arm, that was my flashlight!
Literally, the whole time!
*Inhales more irony of situation from previous statement at 3:42*
Oh man... that's terrifying.
Okay. I- I haven't been looking very closely for things, so I'm going to try to look.
For things.
Eeee... spooky
*realistic thunder clap*
Okay. So there's gotta be, or there may not be- there may not be anything for me to get in here.
What is that? [gasp]
Oh, okay, I thought that was blood stains on the wall. It was just curtains.
[thumping sounds]
Oh my god
What am I doing?
oh my god OH MY GOD
Oh that's so creepy
Can he see my flashlight? (yes)  I don't know
Oh man
That's so weird
[Rain in the background]
Hey, buddy
Hey!
Which way you going, buddy?
Which way you going?
So it doesn't seem like there's any other door around here
It just kinda seems like it's an enclosed space
And there's just me and him, him and me! Alone! Together!
Mano e mano!
In a house
Can he spot me from all the way down the hallway?
Probably
The answer's probably yes
(Silently)kay
Where did he go?
I don't know where he went
He like, vanished
Is he over there?
I think I see a flashlight movin'
Or like, his eyeballs movin'
Ooo, uh oh, uh oh
Oh no
Ooh!
*nervous inhale*
ouAAAHH FUCK YOU
OHHH GOD
WOAH SHIT
OH FUCK
OH GOD
[sounds of running behind him]
OOOOOOOOOOOOO FUCK MEEEE
[Screaming]
[Freddy scream]
Haugh
Augh
So once he gets ya...
He's got you good
He's got ya forever
There's no escaping him
Holy shit
That is sooo cool
That has... so much potential.
I'm gonna go in one more time, not that there's anything else for me to discover
Unless there is, I'm gonna look very hard, but...
I don't know if there is, but I might try this one more time
And we shall see... what I find
So that was... Yeah
Oh! It's all of 'em!
Oh, I- I didn't see Bonnie's ears before
(santaplier) why are Bonnie's eyes red?
Holy shit
That's no good at all
Alright, here we go
[ Hellish jazz music playing again]
I can't read that. Why can't I read anything here?
I'm like, blind. I went in without my glasses
[door creaks)
Alright, let's do this, buddy
[door closes behind)
Okay, so first I'm gonna scan everything in the environment
But it just seems to be repeating basic stuff
[sharp inhale]
Skedaddle, skedaddle
Woahh side-step like a b0ss
Okay
So there's gotta be
I mean, there doesn't GOTTA be anything
There definitely doesn't gotta be anything
It could just be emptiness
For as far as the eye can see
Oh... OH... You creepy
And I think that's what it is
Like, of course this is an alpha so there's no real game
YET!
OH DUDUDUDU
Wait, is he coming this way?
I don't think he's coming this way
Eee
[Thumping sounds getting louder]
Woah
Woooah boy
[thumping sounds]
Which way's he going?
[mechanical noise]
What is that?
What is that?!
That was something!
That was new!
What was that?!
(mechanical noises])
Oh, it's just him
It's just him activating his servos and going every whichaway
Anything in the goddamn trash can?
Ouh...
Why is that the only working light in this whole place?
Just to identify the center of the map
This would be ludicrously scary on VR
I mean like, VR with just playing with the gamepad cause you couldn't obviously...
Walk around the building, but..
Ouh
I'm gonna try to sneak up behind him
[thumping sounds]
WOAHH OH HOH
WOAH WOAH WOAH WOAH WOAH
HuhuhuhuHU
Woah holy shit
Woah...
Okay, he's going that way
[thumping]
Here we go
[Walking gets louder)
[extreme inhale)
Did he hear me?
*quiet thunder striking*
Oh...
No...
That was just his shadows playing with me...
*thumping intensifies*
Oh my GOD!
OH MY GOD!!
[Click]
This is-
[super scary Freddy scream] AH F*CK
OH GOD
UGHHH
I don't know what I expected!
He doesn't like the [voice crack] flAsHLiGHT
Woah...
Okay
Alright, so
That is... The Joy of Creation.
That is awesome! The animations of him are actually pretty phenomenal
Like, that game in its entirety
The potential for this to have something more is really good.
There's a lot of potential here.
I wanna see more of this, even though it has a few bugs, but obviously this is just the demo.
This's just an alpha. It's not even a game yet.
It's just a tech demo.
And- but what it is... is amazing and terrifying, even if it wasn't Five Nights at Freddy's.
This is a good concept.
But the fact that it's an animatronic scares me personally, just because I hate mannequins and animatronics.
So! Thank you everybody so much for watching!
If you want to see me play Those Nights at Rachel's, which is made by the same guy,
Obviously, this person knows quality...
Minus a few bugs,
But knows quality in general.
So let me know in the comments, and thank you, everybody, so much for watching!
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh bye!
(rad Markiplier outro music playing)